david bonjour le corps enseignant et ea
parmi les premières profession en grève
contre cette réforme des retraites
il poursuit donc sa mobilisation malgré
les 500 millions d'euros promis par le
ministère de l'éducation pour compenser
les effets de la future réforme 500
millions d'euros qui est servirait qu'à
compenser l'inflation pour les huit cent
soixante dix mille professeurs français
et une somme très inférieure à ce qui
serait nécessaire pour maintenir le
niveau actuel des pensions c'est pour
cela que parents d'élèves et professeurs
se sont réunis ici devant la mairie du
xième arrondissement de paris afin a
tout d'abord de retirer le projet de loi
de réforme sur les retraites mais
également pour dénoncer les conditions
de travail déplorables en termes de
temps et de qualité de cours et pour
cela ils se sont vêtus de noir couleur
du deuil pour se faire entendre ils ont
également mis en place une chorégraphie
sur le lac à des signes en référence aux
danseuses de l'opéra de paris qui l ont
obtenu gain de cause
récemment je me trouve actuellement avec
fanni a fleuri fanny fleurier
professeurs des écoles bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions pourquoi c'est
important pour vous d'être là ce matin
c'est important parce que ça fait 17 ans
que je travaille
un métier qui me plaît et que je le vois
abîmé au quotidien méprisé par les
gouvernants on ne nous donne plus jamais
aucun moyen on nous demande des missions
supplémentaires et là cette réforme des
retraites c'est le coup de grâce
le coup de grâce à une et du canadien
d'éducation nationale qui est déjà en
grand danger
chaque année avec ce qu'on appelle la
dlg c'est à dire la petite part de
gâteau d'heure qu'on nous donne on est
obligé de partager les miettes entre
collègues pour essayer de faire notre
métier c'est à dire pour enseigner et là
on nous dit que pour compenser les 30%
de retraite qu'on va perdre
eh bien il va falloir une fois de plus
assuré des missions qui ne devraient pas
être les nôtres je parle de mission
d'orientation je parle de mission de
secrétariat
je parle de d'accueillir dans nos
classes des élèves aux handicaps lourds
pour lesquels nous n'avons strictement
aucun moyen preuve supplémentaire ni
formation ce qui ont pâti du coup ce
sont les cours et la qualité des cours
évidemment il ya des gens qui eux
seraient utiles pour faire toutes ces
missions là nous notre métier c'est
enseigner c'est un métier qui est déjà
complet et complexe qu'on ne nous laisse
plus faire correctement et ce qui est
très inquiétant et c'est pour ça qu'on
est là la solidarité des parents depuis
quelques temps c'est que les vocations
pour ce métier là elles s'éteignent
parce que être payés au lance-pierre
pour faire un métier qui n'est plus le
nôtre visa bizarrement ça ça fait plus
rêver et du tonnerre qui sont directes
sur les concours sur les concours
justement puisqu'il ya de plus en plus
ou moins en moins de personnes qui
veulent passer ce concours d'éducation à
moi je suis tutrice un de professeurs
stagiaires et je les vois de moins en
moins motivés
le niveau du concours il va baisser et
nos enfants ils auront des profs au
rabais et ce sera pas étonnant quand on
nous paye moins est contre nous demande
de faire des choses qui ne sont pas
inutiles mais qui ne sont pas de notre
ressort
normalement merci beaucoup fanny d'abord
à nos questions vous l'aurez compris la
mobilisation donc se poursuit non
seulement pour cette réforme de
retraites mais aussi pour les conditions
de travail des professeurs le cortège
devait ensuite rejoindre celui de
montparnasse pour pouvoir retirer à tout
simplement ce projet de loi de réforme
sur les retraites et dénoncé également
les conditions de travail des
professeurs merci beaucoup david khalifa
depuis le 11e arrondissement de paris là